Hey ah hi didn't see you there
actually I did so a lot of you have been
asking why I haven't posted any a
special episode or music video spoof sir
very many videos lately well you know
I'm just gonna gonna be honest with you
I've been a little busy that was walking
in the night just somehow magically got
mayo all over my foot we're trying to
see if it was me detect honor if there's
one of these two males smells even worse
so we have packet here and then I just
started freaking out properly right here
you know like seriously I'm just really
busy like I'm up this year so far
leading by five eggs No
so when I say I was busy like I mean I'm
like doing really important things and
just you know
yeah I'm using a pendant for thick
because I don't know where that I have a
ton of pics everywhere there's pics
everyone man can someone please stop
playing these clips who's losing control
of this yo yo yo yo what's up your super
oh it's magenta he was here in that
house
no because it's making me look like I
haven't been busy and I just I'm having
this conversation with everyone on
YouTube that's watching this video right
now that I've been busy and trying to
tell them how busy oh thanks I'm just
gonna go downstairs oh there's a guy
coming there's a guy coming okay go back
down now
he's gonna see you're filming it in a
terrace
gosh I'm so nervous right how are you
not nervous this I don't know no more
we're done we're done here
done well hello there everybody I am
here TV show why I tell you stop playing
these video clips okay so we're here
here extreme ease
oh yeah hey streaming I got my name on
my chair you are so hot right now you
are so hot right now
you exceeded my camera dock dare you how
dare you
I we're here the streamys